بين مساعده للحليف وتصعيد ضد القطب الاخر
يستمر تدفق المعدات الغربيه لاوكرانيا في
حربها ضد روسيا فواشنطن ومنذ بدايه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا لم تقطع شريان
المساعدات العسكريه عن حليفه هاكيف
وتعتبرها موسكو تسعيدا للحرب التي تنتهي
خطه جديده طرحتها اداره الرئيس الامريكي
جوبيدا بارسال معدات الكترونيه متطوره الى
اوكرانيا تستطيع تحويل الذخائر الجويه الى
قنا
على بحر اي جهد روسي لتحقيق اي مكاسبه في
الحرب ونتوقع ان تعلن الولايات المتحده عن
شحنات اسلحه جديده في وقت قريب قدره على
استهداف المواقع العسكريه بدقه وامكانيه
تثبيت على انواع من الاسلحه هي ما يميز
القنابل الذكيه معتمده على اجهزه تحديد
واقع العالميه تدخل في اطار ما يسميه
البنتاجون ذخيره الهجوم المباشر المشترك
اداره لم توافق بعده على تقديم المعدات
الذكيه الى انها قد تفعل في وقت قريب
بالتزامن مع دراستها لتقديم الصواريخ
باتريوت التي طلبت بها كاف مساعدات جديده
اثرت غضب موسكو التي اعتبرت الخطوه
الامريكيه تصعيدا للوضع
في الثالثه عشر من ديسمبر اعلنت الولايات
المتحده انها ستزود اوكرانيا بانظمه
صواريخ باتريوت في السابق شكك الكثير من
الخبراء واخرون على الجانب الاخر من
المحيط الاطلسي في منطقيه هذه الخطوه
لانها ستؤدي الى تصعيد الصراع وزياده
الخطر مع جيران الجيش الامريكي بشكل مباشر
الى الصراع
نزف حاد في البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه
نتيجه الاستهداف الروسي المستمر لها حرم
الاوكرانيين من الطاقه خلال الشتاء الحرب
ما دفع كيف للمطالبه باسلحه جديده لوقف
الهجمات على اوكرانيا